so you've seen the equations for how to
infer and - norm for maybe a single
hidden layer let's see how it fits in to
the training of a deep network so let's
figure of a neural network like this
you've seen me say before that you can
view each hidden unit as computing two
things first it computes Z and then it
applies the activation function to
compute a and so you can think of each
of these circles as representing a two
step computation and similarly for the
next layer that's V 2 1 and a 2 1 and so
on so if you were not supplying bascomb
you would have an input X feed into the
first hidden layer and then first
compute z1 and this is governed by the
parameters W 1 and B 1 and then
ordinarily you would feed Z 1 into the
activation function to compute a 1 but
what we'll do in batchelomez take this
value Z 1 and apply national sometimes
abbreviated BN to it and that's going to
be governed by parameters beta 1 and
gamma 1 and this will give you this new
normalized value V 1 and then you feed
that to the activation function to get a
1 which is a G 1 applied to V tilde 1
now you've done the computation for the
first layer where this passion ohms that
really occurs you know in between the
computation from Z and a next you take
this value a 1 and use it to compute V 2
and so this is now governed by W 2 B 2
and similar to what you did for the
first layer you would take me 2 and
apply it through passional reading that
BN now this is governed by rational
parameters specific to the next layer
beta 2 gamma 2 and now this gives you
the total - and you use that to compute
a 2 by applying G activation function
and so on so once again the Batchelor
ohms that you know kind of happens
between computing Z and computing a and
the intuition is that instead of using
the unnormalized value Z you're going to
use the normalized value V Tilda that's
in the first layer and the second layer
as well as they're using the unknown
value z2 you're going to use the mean
and variance normalized values Z tilde -
so the parameters or your network are
going to be W 1 B 1 it turns out we'll
get rid of the B parameters that we'll
see why in the next slide but for now
imagine your parameters are the usual W
1 B 1 3w l BL and we've added to this
new network additional parameters beta 1
gamma 1 beta 2 gamma 2 and so on you
know for each layer in which you are
applying bash mall for clarity note that
these betas here these nothing to do
with the hyper parameter beta that we
had for momentum over the computing the
various exponentially weighted averages
you know the authors of the atom paper
had used beta in their paper to denote
that hyper parameter the authors that
the Bashan on paper had used data to
denote this parameter but these are two
completely different betas I decided to
stick with beta in both cases in case
you read the original papers but the
beta 1 beta 2 and so on that - norm
tries to learn is a different data than
the hyper parameter beta used in
momentum and in the abdomen rmsprop
algorithms but so now that these are the
new parameters of your algorithm you
would then use whether optimization you
want such as gradient descent in order
to implement it so for example you might
compute D beta
all forgiven layer and then update the
parameters beta gets updated as beta -
learning rate times e beta l and you can
also use atom or RS prop or momentum in
order to update the parameters beta and
gamma
not just gradient descent and even
though in the previous video I'll
explain what the bash zone operation
does confuse me in in variances in
subtraction / them if they're using a
deep learning programming framework
usually you won't have to implement the
bash norm step on a Shalom layer
yourself then so the program framework
so it can be one line of code so for
example in the tender flow framework you
can implement batch normalization with
you know this function will talk more
about programming frameworks later but
in practice you might not end up needing
to implement all these details yourself
but it's still worth knowing how it
works
so you can get a better understanding of
what your code is doing but implementing
backbone is often you know something
like one line of code in the deep
learning frameworks now so far we've
talked about bash them as if you were
training on your entire training side at
a time as if you're using batch gradient
descent in practice bash them is usually
applied with mini batches of your
training sets so the way you actually
apply bash them is you take your first
mini batch and compute z1 same as we did
on the previous slide using the
parameters W 1 b1 and then you take this
just this mini batch and compute the
mean and variance of the Z ones on just
this mini batch and then bash norm with
subtract by the mean and divide by the
standard deviation and then rescale by
beta 1 gamma 1 to give you V 1 and all
this is on the first mini batch then
you'll apply the activation function you
know to get a 1 oh and then you compute
V 2 using
w2 b 2 and so on
so you do all this in order to perform
one step of say gradient descent on the
first mini badge and then you go to the
second mini batch x2 and you do
something similar where will you now
compute z1 on the second mini badge and
then use batch them to compute z1 tilde
and so here in this - known step you'd
be normalizing veto they are using just
the data in your second mini batch so
this - don't stop here is looking at the
examples in your second mini batch
computing the mean and variance is of
the V ones on just a mini batch and then
rescaling by beta and gamma to get the
two there and so on and you do this with
a third mini batch and keep training
now that's one detail to the
parameterization that I want to clean up
which is previously I said that the
parameters was WL BL finish layer as
well as beta L and gamma L now notice
that the way VL is computed is as
follows ZL equals W L times a of L minus
1 plus B of L but what - column does is
going to look at the mini batch and
normalize dll - first set mean 0 and
standard variance and in a rescale by
beta and gamma but what that means is
that whatever the value of B L is
actually going to just get subtracted
out because during that bashful
normalization step you're going to
compute the means of the V else and and
subtract out the mean and so adding any
constant to all of the examples in a
mini - it doesn't change anything
because any constant you add will get
cancelled out by the mean subtraction
step so if you're using bash norm you
can actually eliminate that parameter or
if you want to think of it as setting it
permanently to zero so then the
parameterization becomes V L is just WL
x al minus 1 oh and then you compute
VL normalized and we compute Z tilde
equals gamma ZL plus beta you end up
using this parameter beta L in order to
decide what the mean of Z tilde L which
is what gets passed the link layer so
just a recap because bash norm zeroes
out the mean of these VL values in the
layer there's no point having this
parameter BL and so you might as well
get rid of it and instead it's sort of
replaced by beta L which is a parameter
that controls that ends up affecting the
shift or the bias terms finally remember
that the dimension of VL because if
you're doing this on one example is
going to be NL by one and so BL at
dimension n L by 1 if n L is the number
of hidden units in layer L and so the
dimension of beta L and gamma L is also
going to be ml by one because um that's
the number of hidden juniors you have
you have NL hidden units and so beta and
gamma L are used to scale the mean and
variance of each of the hidden units to
whatever the network wants to set them
to so let's go all together and describe
how you can implement gradient descent
using rational assuming you're using
mini-batch gradient descent you iterate
for T equals 1 to the number of mini
batches you would implement for prop on
mini-batch XT and during forward prop in
each hidden layer um use bash norm to
replace VL with Z tilde L and so this
ensures that within that mini badge the
value V end up with some normalized mean
and the
and the values and the version with the
normalize mean and variance is this Z
tilde L and then you use back prop to
compute DW DB for all the values of L D
beta P gamma although technically since
we've gotten rid of B this actually now
goes away and then finally you update
the parameters so you know W gets
updated as W minus the learning rate
times this as usual beta is updated as
theta minus the learning rate times DB
and similarly for gamma and if you've
computed the gradients as follows you
can use gradient descent that's what
I've written down here but this also
works with gradient descents with
momentum or rmsprop um or Adam where
instead of taking this gradient descent
update you can use the updates given by
these other algorithms as we discuss in
the previous week's videos so these are
the optimization algorithms as well can
be used to update the parameters beta
and gamma that passional added to your
algorithm so I hope that gives you a
sense of how you could implement a song
from scratch if you want to do if you're
using one of the deep learning
programming frameworks which we'll talk
more about later hopefully you can just
call someone else's implementation in
the Prima framework which would make
using bash storm much easier now in case
national still seems a little bit
mysterious um if you know still not
quite sure why speeds up training so
dramatically let's go to the next video
and talk more about why - Tom really
works and what is really doing